hey guys i'm ryan right today I'm doing
watching a special trailer for a film
called catch a short film actually and
it's directed by this guy named David
Henry I think you wrote it to actually
I'm not sure anyway this film I'm taking
interested in because of david henrie i
follow this guy on Instagram and I saw
that he has been promoting this short
film a lot on television shows and stuff
so I was like this sounds interesting
and then I kind of went on a david
henrie little but again pinch I started
like looking up everything this guy's
done and stuff and like he was a wizards
of waverly place this Way's really well
known for is a plane Selena Gomez his
brother Justin something or another on
the show but this guy's actually don't
like a lot of drama work and he sees
some really talented dude and you know
whenever someone from Disney surprises
me like that that's what I'm like very
impressive very impressive you're more
than just a joke and like from my
understanding is short films were
getting a lot of good feedback and since
I'm like his new number one fan I was
like I'm gonna check out this trailer I
was looking down my computer right now
so I'm like [ __ ] it let's check it out
together because she has a no david
henrie is there's a picture of him once
right yeah suck that dick him and his
pale body right here we go people played
in Cleveland Palm Beach Beverly Hills
it's about seeing you catch not gay
catch
this looks directed really well he's
gonna kill his father oh my god is he
gonna do it
it's been a labor of the line for a long
time it's been my dream since I was a
little kid who powerful stories stories
that you watch and it make a difference
in your life that you lead wanting to be
a better person wanting to instill
change in your community bring more love
to your family that's true this was the
real love for make sense that it's a
type of story that I dreamed to tell for
the rest of my life and love father-son
story and a game of catch means so much
more to a boy he's good looking Amir
throwing with a ball back and forth and
I think it's something that the that
people in America especially need to be
reminded of how important it is to spend
quality time with your boy Hakeem Akash
is that I didn't even realize it when I
was writing it just he kind of looks
like a hi ryan gosling praying I hope
that you'll share it with your families
with your friends and whatever you think
that it will help so thank you very much
have a good it looks like a really sweet
short film I like a good drama you know
like a lot of the trailers I end up
watching or like action based and stuff
but a good drama to me is like those
really moving pictures i really get
heart warmed by you know they're they're
good stuff especially father and son
stuff anything to do parents I crimes
anything to do a parents that's seen him
liar liar when he's finally going
through that character arc and realize
how much he loves his son and how it
should be there for him always [ __ ]
catch me so yeah I guess I gotta buy it
so I'm gonna buy it and yeah I hope
David watches this video David if you're
watching
you and I must make a pact we must bring
salvation back where there is love I'll
be there I'll be there listen baby ain't
no mountain high ain't no Valley low
jump beautiful getting jiggy with it no
no no no no not anyway yeah check that
short film out and I'm gonna check it
out to you we can watch it together
maybe even do a little review on a short
film never done that before if you're if
you knew the channel um subscribe hen my
neighbors are so loud today I tell him
to shut the [ __ ] up in a really loud to
me a voice mine my windows are open and
I'm a [ __ ] I'm gonna do some shout outs
most important part of the video exhale
TZ Kenny's x yo Ryan you don't have to
give me a shout out but if you can that
would be awesome man well guess what
dude here's your shoutout you're getting
shot out from me you should feel so
lucky dude getting shot up it's your
lucky day hahaha Jordan night he said
hey dude I'm 14 okay he's a fan I don't
just know some random fourteen-year-old
kid and love your channel please please
please can I have a shout out buddy I am
British so yeah oh so because you're
British uh yeah you deserve a shout out
yes you got that right my friend Brits
all the way Brits have nice tits
referring to the ladies Brits also have
nice dicks referring to the men Brits
you got your lips but their teeth are
known to be bad oh nine Jack Daniels you
guys are hilarious but I'm offended as a
new sub that I didn't get my name called
lawman I know it's been quite some time
since you had this request but we
finally got around to you cuz there is a
list that I have to go in order of own I
Jack Daniels drink up my friend I don't
know his drink beer but when I do I
prefer
Jack Daniels is the stockies as if it
was the psyches